hey everyone welcome to this video on
cyber security interview questions part
two
here you will have an overview of
various software and programming
questions that can be asked when you
apply for a job in the cyber security
domain
our experienced instructor bipin will
take you through these questions
so let's get started but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from simplylearn
first question being how do you keep a
computer secure
now this is going to be a very generic
question so
you want to put your best foot forward
and you want to
identify the most common methodologies
on how we can keep a computer secure
so when we talk about computers the
first thing that you want to talk about
is authentication mechanisms
where you want multi-factor
authentication or two-way authentication
to ensure
that your accounts are kept secured now
if you look at
using passwords depending on how
passwords are being stored by the
application
uh password attacks can be possible
either a brute force attack or a
dictionary based attack
or even password guessing attacks are
possible to mitigate those kind of
attacks
you we need multi-factor authentication
to ensure that
accounts are kept secure now even if we
are
using multi-factor authentication we
also want to look at secure
passwords which means that
the password is complex enough to
withstand most of the common attacks
and a brute force attack or a dictionary
attack is just not possible
so we want to randomize our passwords we
want to create a complexity where a
password meets
standard such as me has at least
one lowercase one uppercase character
has numerics
and special characters and is randomized
as not based on a dictionary word
doesn't contain usernames email
addresses phone numbers or anything that
is personal to that particular
user third keep regular updates
which means that there will be patches
that will be released for the
application for the software that you're
utilizing
download the patches install them on a
regular basis to ensure that
you are secured against the most recent
attacks that have been identified
install a good antivirus could be an
internet security
suite which will have an antivirus
intrusion detection system a firewall
and will help you protect yourself
against ransomwares
malwares and any script-based attacks
also have a specialized firewall on your
system
could be a host-based firewall or a
network-based firewall to ensure that
attacks are kept at a minimum and you
have your network definitions
in place to allow or disallow
connections from happening to your
devices
have anti-phishing software installed as
well to ensure that
you are not getting any spam mails even
if you do you are able to identify that
and not fall free or victim to those
spam males phishing attacks are generic
where they are directed towards
individuals
and they prey on the calibrity of that
particular individual so our nigerian
frauds
or the lotteries that we win on a
regular basis of hundreds of million
dollars
those messages the emails that we
receive they are all phishing emails
where
they're basically prone to victimize the
user and then drop them off money or
install some malware or do some other
malicious activity
if you want to enhance encryption about
data that you have stored on your
devices
or on your or that is accessed by your
software or being transmitted by your
software
use encryption encrypt your data whether
it is at rest whether it is in motion or
whether it is at use
thus reducing data leakage and data loss
possibilities and finally in the
foremost secure your dns dns is the
domain name
server which is utilized by
computers to resolve domain names to ip
addresses
if a dns poisoning attack is possible
where your dns settings have been
modified by an attacker and you are
redirected to a malicious dns server
that server is going to redirect you to
another malicious application
which may have a malware or a malicious
software
as a payload also you don't want
people to know your dns servers and the
queries that you're making
so you want to use secure dns or dns
over https
to encrypt your dns queries as well
so in a nutshell if you follow these
eight steps
your devices your computers your
applications are going to be as secure
as possible
the next question discuss security
related aspects between c
c plus plus and java now this is an
open-ended question it depends on which
level
you're giving an interview on but you're
looking at it from a freshers
perspective
or a less experienced perspective and
thus these are some of the aspects that
we want to look at and the comparisons
between cc plus plus and java
so the five aspects that we are looking
at are pointers
code translations storage allocation
inheritance and overall
security are based on cc plus and java
so when we say pointers we are looking
at
how we are going to uh we are using
pointers
and stacks and heaps to point to
functions and how
we exit those functions and how those
functions are then recalled into the
next function so
c supports pointers it is most secure c
plus plus also supports point pointers
but it is a little bit less secure than
c
java it is not supported turret access
is given to memory allocation
and thus it is the least secure as far
as pointers are concerned
when we look at code translations c
is able to compile but it is not secure
same with cc plus plus
but in java it does an interpreted
language and it is abstracted and
secured
in storage allocation in c we use malloc
and
catalog memory allocation which is less
secure because it does not have internal
checks on
verifying what memory is allocated and
the user input that is being
compiled or that is being input to that
memory
right thus this can allow buffer
overflow errors
uh to creep in because of the uh
non verification of the input data so it
is the least secure
in cc plus plus it uses new and delete
uh options and it's comparatively secure
but java uses a garbage collector
and does is the most secure as far as
storage allocation is concerned
when we talk about inheritance the most
secure is ccp plus plus c has no
inheritance so it's not secure
in c plus plus it is supported does
it is the most secure whereas in java
there's multi inheritance that is not
supported
and does is comparatively secure
overall the most secure out of all these
based on these five aspects is java
the least secure is c and the
mid level is c plus plus moving on to
question 13
what are the different sources of
malware now malware stands for malicious
software
right malware is basically a software
that poses as a legitimate software but
has a payload of a trojan virus
spyware keylogger or some malicious
software that is going to have
a negative impact on security of your
particular device
so the question here is what are the
different sources of malware
we want to identify the most common
sources
through which malwares infect end user
devices in today's world
and you can start with pop-up ads so
most of the websites if you're visiting
untrusted sites if you're being
redirected to sites that you don't know
about
there'll be a lot of pop-ups coming your
way when it says you're the one
millionth
visitor to this site please click here
to download your gift
or it will say congratulations on
winning a particular
product for visiting this page and so on
so forth there are some
instances where you can see a banner
which is flashing at you
on top of the page and says that there
are eight
uh infections that have been identified
on your computer click here to download
an antivirus to clean the infections so
all of these pop-ups
are there as a social engineering attack
as a phishing attack
to make gullible people click on those
links and download those
malwares now the software that is posing
as a security software
itself can be a malicious software which
is going to install a trojan or a virus
or a bot
on your machine compromising the
security of that machine
the second is removable media usbs and
humans have a fascination with usb
so if you find a usb lying around
it's a free usb you get excited about it
and you want to
take it home you want to plug it into a
machine and see what's on the usb
worst case scenario you format it and
you've got a free usb to utilize
higher the capacity the better but that
is one of the most
easiest way people use
malwares to uh to be deployed on
unsuspecting users if there is a usb
lying around
why would why would somebody want to
forget a usb it's most likely planted
over there
as a social engineering attack so that a
gullible person is going to pick it up
plug it into their device if the device
is not secured enough
it is going to install the malware right
then documents and executable files this
is where your viruses
and all those keeps in so let's say
you're surfing on the internet you're
looking for a software
uh and you find the software on a
particular website
you do not verify the trustworthiness of
that site
and you just download and install that
software now that software could be
malware as well does if you're surfing
on the internet you're downloading files
from different locations you have to
research the website you have to
research the source
to ensure that it is trustworthy and
only then are you going to download and
execute those files
thus internet downloads as well and when
we say internet downloads it's not just
untrustworthy sites we go to torrents uh
we go to
uh the dark web or the deep web and
searching for other softwares
especially uh those who are researching
security right
we always want we are always on the
lookout of new softwares
and we are always on those forums which
may not be so much
trustworthy and we just download those
files and start installing them
that is a very bad scenario right so you
have to be very careful what you are
downloading from the internet
your anti-viruses your uh anti-fishing
uh mechanisms your threat intelligence
mechanisms
uh have those uh mechanisms installed
and you want to verify where your
downloads are coming from
then your network connections if it is a
p2p connection it is a local area
network connection or a metropolitan
area network you have to verify whom
which devices are connected to your
machines and you have to
validate those connections before you
want to trust those devices
uh and before you connect to them if
you're on a public wi-fi
you probably don't want to connect to a
public wi-fi in the first place
then comes email attachments
there are so many attachments that come
across in today's world most of them in
a zip format or a rar format
uh some of them come as document files
where there are macros hidden within
them
macros are scripts that are recognized
by microsoft office files
right and then finally there are these
malicious advertisements that we
find online right uh let it be facebook
let it be whatsapp let it be
uh any social media platform that you go
or even your search engines their job is
to display ads
their job is not to verify whether the
ad is legit or not
it is for us as consumers to be careful
and validate that ad and verify whether
it is a genuine ad or not
so just don't start clicking on any of
the ad trusting
uh the platform that you're on be
sure that you are investigating that so
these are the most
common sources of malware and
the end user will always get infected by
one of these mechanisms
moving on to question 14
how does email work now this is a very
uh
can be a complex question but we have to
keep it as simple
as possible and we have to identify that
there are
uh two servers while uh both of them
either using smtp which is a simple
message transfer protocol
where in this scenario john
wants to send an email thus they've got
an email client installed on their
machine
which is connected to the mail exchange
server which has a dns server
which maps the routing and which maps
the exchange server
and inboxes so when john composes that
message and clicks on send
john should be connected to a mail
exchange server
where the email is sent through that
particular person's inbox
so john's inbox will then uh
be validated and that email will then be
sent through the dns server
uh through the internet and will be
received by the
recipient mail server so at this point
in time john also requires
the recipient's email address so in this
case this is jack
so jack at something dot com would be uh
the email address
so while john is composing uh the two
field will have jack's email address
the from field will have john's email
address the subject field will have
whatever they want to convey as a
message the message body will have the
message itself
and then when uh john clicks on send it
will go to
direction server the exchange server
will then validate the
inbox and identify where that inbox is
located
for jack and then through the internet
it will be sent
to the uh to the mail server of jack the
mail server will then identify the
proper
inbox that it now that that email is to
be sent to and it will store that email
in that particular inbox
when jack opens their computer and
accesses their inbox
this email from john will be already
waiting for them
and they can respond to it the same way
john had sent that email
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more moving on to question 15
what are the types of threats a company
can face
right and this is where your threat
modeling comes into the picture so
you're looking at software as you're
looking at operating systems
and the company comes and asks you uh
what are the threats that are most
likely
that a company will face so on a broader
scale the threats that a company will
always face
would be classified as natural threats
man-made threats
technical threats and a supply system
threat
so a natural threat would be an act of
god which is outside the control of
human beings
could be storms or any natural
occurrences like
volcanoes thunderstorms flooding
earthquakes fire and so on so forth so
anything that is natural so it depends
on the geographic location that you're
in
and what kind of climate that area faces
and you need to
identify the immediate threats and
prepare for them so if it is
flooding that you're looking at and you
want to look at an office
and the possibility of the office
getting flooded is real
you probably want to take office at a
higher floor
so that the threat of flooding is
minimized
for fire we always have a fire drill
where we practice our fire mechanism so
that we can evacuate all humans as soon
as possible
and then worry about the technicalities
of
it under any circumstances under any
threats
humans will always have the first
priority and then
everything else comes in manmade threats
are
where man themselves are a problem so
strikes lockouts
hackers theft war
writing all of those are man-made
threats
uh which we ourselves cannot be in
control of
but we need to plan for them and we need
to have
uh a business continuity plan or a
disaster requiem plan for any of these
threats that have been identified
then come the technical threats
technical could be software bugs
operating system bugs application bugs
that
uh that come with the applications that
we have or a hardware failure where a
server crashes
or hard disk crashes maybe
the processor stops working the
motherboard stops working
ram gets corrupted any of the technical
aspects
a stopping stop functioning does
creating a break in the business can
come under technical
right so uh anything to do with
computers
let's say a server failing or a
patch that is not installed on the
particular software those would come
under technical
threats and then the supply system the
supply system are your environmental
threats
which require depend on your supply
chain field failures
what is the supply chain for the office
to function there are a lot of
dependencies that office goes through
right there are a lot of other vendors
that suppose
that support and provide critical
infrastructure non-critical
infrastructure for the office to
function
for first and foremost electricity
without electricity nothing is going to
be powered on
and you are not going to be able to
function so if there is an electricity
service provider
and if there is an electric outage
that's that comes under supply system
so that's a supply chain failure where
the
vendor that provides electricity to you
has failed in providing that particular
service
and now you need a business continuity
or a disaster recovery plan
so you probably have an inverter or you
already have a
power generator plant that is going to
generate your own power and supply to
your system
right they could be short circuits
because of fluctuation in the
electricity
uh maybe the internet service provider
fails and your internet caches so you
have a backup line for the internet from
a different vendor
right and so on so forth maybe your
hardware vendors who are supplying you
servers desktops laptops and whatnot
they fail because they feel they are
facing a strike or they go bankrupt and
suddenly
you can no longer purchase hardware from
your vendor because they no longer
are in business so that's a supply chain
failure so any of these systems failing
would also come under threats
so under a broad category these are the
first four threads that you need to
identify and then you can
elaborate by providing more scenarios
based on the experiences that you have
had
towards each and every of these threats
so natural threat where you may have had
experience
where there would have been let's say
flooding or
any natural disaster which caused a
problem for the
continuity of your particular business
so identify each and every
example for each of these threats and
provide that as an example
in the interview what is black box and
white box testing
so when you are testing a software or
you're testing your infrastructure
there are two different tests that you
can conduct the first one
is a black box the second one is a white
box
in a black box test there is no
knowledge that is shared with the tester
so
let's say you're an ethical hacker and
you have been awarded a contract by an
organization
to test the current application that
they have developed
now they are not going to give you any
information they are not going to tell
you what the application
is they just probably give you an ip
address and a port number where the
application is hosted
and now you have to file in your own
queries and try to figure out
what the application is try to gather
information
see what uh what information can be
gathered in the first place
and based on that you're going to figure
out your way identify your
vulnerabilities
and see if any of those vulnerabilities
can lead to an security incident
so without any knowledge zero knowledge
of the id infrastructure
or the source code that's a black box
attack or a black box
test a white box test on the other hand
is where full knowledge of the id
infrastructure or the source code is
shared
so the ethical hacker has complete
knowledge
and based on the knowledge they are then
going to test out the system to see if
there are any flaws that they can
identify
right so why would these two audits be
important
because the first one a black box audit
emulates
the attack of a outsider a external
hacker sitting
outside the organization trying to
figure their way in whereas a white box
attack
can emulate the attack of an insider so
a disgruntled employee within that
organization
misusing their access controls or the
access rights
to make uh unvalidated profits
right so somebody's corrupt who has been
bribed
who wants to sell out company secrets
based uh so they're going to try to find
out vulnerabilities
try to steal data and try to sell it on
the uh
gray market right so a white box would
emulate a internal attack
a black box would emulate an external
attack moving on to question 17
what is use case testing now use case
testing is a functional test
and it is also a black box test right
what is a functional test
it tests the functionality of a
particular software once it has been
created
why is it a black box test because the
user doesn't know what the functionality
is they just want to find out each and
every scenario
and try to see what that scenario
generates as a response
they are not sure whether that is the
appropriate response that should be
generated or
not they're just trying to find out the
response
that is going to be generated after they
fire off a query
so this technique is used by testers to
get the test scenarios to exercise the
whole system
from start to finish so let's say it's a
login mechanism for an application
right now a user at this point in time
the tester since it's a black box
testing
will know that it is a login mechanism
they will not know the details of what
logging mechanisms are being utilized so
they wouldn't know whether uh input
validation is done
they wouldn't know whether output
encoding is done they wouldn't know how
the cgi calls are being made
they will not know how the queries are
handled at the server side
and how the database is going to treat
that particular query
so they have no idea whether the sql
injection attacks are possible and so on
and so forth
so for them with whatever input they are
going to try to insert
for that login mechanism that's a
functional black box test
the functionality being whether the
login mechanism works
and based on the type of inputs that are
going to put in
whether it creates an unwarranted output
whether they can bypass the mechanism
or they can hack into the system because
of some of the flaws that were left
behind
right another example here is a software
made for users to use for documentation
the testers will test all the cases that
the user can do so can the user view a
document
can they add new documents can they edit
documents and can they delete documents
so this functionality will depend upon
the access controls that have been
granted to a particular user so for this
particular user the tester at this point
in time
they would not know whether they are an
administrative user or they are a
regular user
they'll just try to do all of these and
then write the responses saying
i was able to view i was able to add i
was able to edit and i was able to
delete
now the result will be then sent to a
manager the manager will
look at the results and then based on
the actual access controls that were
supposed to be there
for this particular user then we'll try
to identify whether this is an
acceptable case
or whether there were any flaws within
this case
moving on to question 18 what is static
and dynamic testing now this is again in
application testing
static testing is done in an early stage
of development life cycle now
software development life cycles there
are multiple of those what are these
life cycles
there are different stages in which a
application is
created and provided to the customer
so your first stage would be determining
the scope of the application
determining the hardware requirements
for that application then
creating a flowchart for that
application a functional chart for that
application
and then maybe start coding then an
architect comes in tests the code
verifies the code
then the testing phase comes in then the
security testing phase comes in
and then the user acceptance testing
comes in but
in every stage at the very earliest of
first stage a static test will always be
started
to see whatever code has been developed
whatever
scope has been developed whether that
scope is going to be correct or not
this will include walkthroughs and code
review what is a walk through
a walkthrough is going through documents
that have been generated
and trying to find faults in the
documented journey that has been talk
that has been created so far so let's
say somebody has created a workflow
or a flowchart for a program how the
functions are going to be called and how
they're going to be executed
so a walkthrough would be where all
these
responsible people will walk through
that particular flowchart and find out
any flaws within that
and then rectify them if there is any
code that has already been written
this code will be reviewed manually and
any flaws within that code would then be
identified
static testing will always be 100
accurate in a very short amount of time
because it is immediate
uh you have created it and then the
expert is going to test it to see
whether everything is fine or not
right it is all about prevention
mechanism so since you're doing it at
the inception itself
if you find any flaw it gets immediately
repaired so this is about preventing
vulnerabilities from keeping into that
application at a later point in time
whereas dynamic on the other side is
done at the end of the development life
cycle so you have generated the
application
everything is ready now you want to do
dynamic testing
includes functional and non-functional
testing functional testing is where
the application itself is being tested
the functions to see that all the
parameters that are given to the
application are functioning properly
non-functional testing would be where
security parameters
administrative parameters all of them
are being verified
right this is where your test case
scenarios come in
and uh you're going to test each and
every scenario
by generating inputs and analyzing the
output that the application is going to
give you
dynamic testing is all about cure so
here you're going to identify
vulnerabilities
report them to the management and the
management is then going to figure out a
way
of patching those vulnerabilities so
that they can be mitigated
moving on to the next question what are
the test levels in software testing
so as far as software testing is
concerned there are four test levels
module testing integration testing
system testing
and the final one is acceptance testing
so in the testing phase of your
development life cycle
the first thing is a module test you're
going to check
your routines your subroutines your sub
programs
procedures that have been written in a
program so all your functions
all your mechanisms for that application
are going to be tested
when you go into integration testing the
software may have been integrated with
multiple softwares there may be
different api calls coming in
maybe a third party software on which
you are depending upon to supply for
information
so all of these integration of various
softwares various apis
are tested to ensure that they are
functioning properly
and there are no flaws errors or
mistakes left behind
in the integration of all of these
softwares
then the system testing is where the
entire system so
including the hardware including the
software right it starts from the
installation
so now the software is complete we know
which hardware we are going to support
for it
we start by installing the software and
see whether the installation is going to
be completed properly
if there are any errors in the
installation process itself
then once it is installed the
performance of that particular
application
the write speeds the read speeds on the
hard disk
uh the transaction speeds that the
application is capable of
the network dependencies that the
application may have all of those would
come under system testing
and then the acceptance testing which is
basically a
quality assurance exercise that
the application meets the client's
requirements
so the client in the first stage would
have given the scope of what needs to be
achieved
in the acceptance testing you are
verifying that that scope has been met
and the client requirements uh have been
met and you can assure the client
about the functionality and the
performance of that particular
application
coming to the last question in this
software programs what are the valuable
steps to resolve
issues while testing so in the previous
scenarios when we have started testing
now if you find out when you execute a
particular use case
and then you find out of law what would
be the
steps that you would utilize to address
those
particular flaws in those tests the
first step will always be record
then you're going to report it and then
you're going to introduce a control
process for it so when you say record
you're going to create logs
and you're going to try to resolve all
the problems that have happened now when
you say resolve
you're not going to record the
application but you're going to test the
system again and again to ensure that
whatever is being recorded is accurate
and all the logs all the error
mechanisms all the dumps
all of those that have been generated
due to this particular log or but due to
this particular
error are being captured so that they
can be reported
to the higher level managers so the next
step is once you have
eventually accumulated all these logs
and records you're going to report them
to the higher level managers
who are then going to investigate it and
go back to the developers
trying to figure out the best way to
mitigate those particular
flaws so the report writing needs also
also needs to be accurate
it needs to be to the point uh it needs
to detail what the problem was it will
document all the steps that there were
that you took all the
inputs that you put in and it will also
record
all the errors and it will also record
all the mechanisms that were utilized
and the
uh errors that were actually generated
and that report will be given to the
higher level managers who can then
forward it to the developers
who based on those reports can draw
start their troubleshooting
and then the control mechanism comes in
you're going to
define the issue management process so
this process needs to work in a
particular manner where you're
doing a test you're recording whatever
is happening you're creating a report
out of it you're sending it to the
management
the management will then take those
reports study them
take it to the developers the developers
will test based on
their criterias they might interact with
the testers at that point in time to
identify particular flaws and then they
might want to record that application on
a developer patch
which once installed will mitigate that
particular flaw
and then it can come back to the testing
phase again where you can repeat those
tests
and validate that the flaw is no longer
existing
so these are the three steps that would
be utilized
for testing purposes and with that we
have come to the end of the cyber
security interview questions part two on
software and programming
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
related to the topics that were covered
in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries
tune in to simply learn to watch out for
more cyber security interview questions
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here